you know I never really had a desire to
write music for movies I always call it
pretty much a happy accident I started
off as a pianist as a young kid and went
through music school and eventually
ended up in rock-and-roll bands and as a
session musician and a couple of the
musicians in the orchestra's I used to
work for us it you know you ought to
write music for TV or pictures someday
and I just never really thought about it
again and then somebody offered me a
movie it was a really silly comedy
called head office if you remember movie
called airplane it was basically the
airplane of the corporate world her and
I turned it down because I was terrified
I had no idea how to write a movie and
they persisted and I eventually said yes
and I fell in love with it and been
doing it ever since you know I never had
that kind of awareness of my own career
but I think I think that probably the
biggest turn for me was either was
probably pretty woman which was 1989
1990 and when I think about doing that
movie and why Gary Marshall hired me I
still not quite sure why he hired me
because I didn't have any work out there
that represented the kind of music that
he wanted so we must have had a good
interview and you just believed in me
probably more than I believed in myself
at the time I worked pretty strictly I
kind of start at 9:00 in the morning
more or less and I worked till about 6
or 7 I used to work seven days a week
and all night and all that stuff but now
that at the tender age of 66 I I try not
to work weekends but I end up inevitably
working weekends when I try and I get
tired after about seven I mean I can
compose for ten hours a day and I'm
pretty fast I can get a lot done but
beyond that it starts to become sort of
a forced march I prefer to start working
as early as possible I mean when the
movies before the movies being shot you
know more and more I find that directors
are very interested in me writing music
based on a script or a conversation and
making demos of it that they can listen
to or they can shoot to or edit to and
there's really a great advantage to that
because I find that more often than not
the music that I write before the film
is being shot ends up in the movie and
and to a large extent plays a very big
role on the movie so I always think of a
director's first experience hearing
music is like when a goose is born and
they imprint on whatever live person or
creature they see as being their parent
and so I like to think the director
first hears my music in their movie and
that's the music they're gonna stick
with if you don't really think about it
in terms of images in the beginning and
you really just think about music that's
what I try and tell young composers is
just focus on music in the beginning
write something that it has a little bit
of substance to it then turn on the
movie and play your music and see if
some of it works and I bet probably a
lot of it will I make very elaborate
demos and I think most people do now I
mean that's just kind of that's been
part of my process I mean you really
need to be familiar with some some kind
of software with for electronic music to
create demos of what the musics gonna
sound like for the director so by the
time that we get into the recording
studio with a giant Orchestra the
directors heard everything and we've
sort of fought most of our battles
I'm extremely hands-on I don't conduct
during my recording because I like to be
in the control room and I really am very
protective of that environment I want to
make sure that every time there's a
playback I have all my pre-record 'he's
the synthesizers the chorus they've done
everything balanced properly because if
it if it's not balanced properly
director can become insecure about well
that cue doesn't sound like it used to
what's wrong so I make sure that every
time there's a playback it sounds
exactly is it supposed to sound
fantastic bees was a situation where
there was a there was a vocabulary
pretty much already established by a guy
named John Williams and wrote some
pretty memorable themes so I I knew that
this was not a Harry Potter movie but it
was in the Harry Potter universe so my
feeling was that he was going to it
still need to be in the same vocabulary
I wanted to get rid of Hedwig steam as
quick as I could and have my own themes
I knew it was going to have to be kind
of sophisticated orchestral writing with
a lot of sort of magical elements and
that always involves a lot of note
writing I was really focused on the
themes and I wrote all of the themes for
the movie before I saw any other movie
and started communicating with David
Yates very early on and we went through
a lot of explorations and I think we all
made the right decision before we were
all
I hope I think it's very hard to keep
things fresh over a you know six or
seven month period which is what some of
these movies are I know I was on
fantastic bees for instance from
November of 16 through September of 17
so that's a lot of time a lot of writing
I'm not sure I think I think if you've
written a good if you have a good
approach it will survive all the the
audience previews and the focus groups
and the in the reiterations and the
constant scrutiny I think what doesn't
survive is it is probably best to just
leave by the by the side by the wayside
plus I have a couple of people around me
that I think are really objective they
know my work really well they know me
really well and of course there's a
collaboration between myself and a
filmmaker that is extremely important
and you know it all it's a team effort
it's it's it's total collaboration
otherwise it's it just doesn't work well
I I you know gosh
I I trying to remember John I got a call
from John Wells who was the executive
producer on ER and he asked me if I
wanted to do a pilot I think he had done
something before that made me think that
this was going to be good and he
described some actor named George
Clooney and these different people I
didn't do much TV back then I was pretty
much doing features and I said sure I'll
do the I'll do the pilot but I don't
want to do the series I'll do the pilot
and then I'm gonna hand it off to my
friend and we did it that way and I
wrote you know I hate to say I hate to
destroy everybody's fantasies and pop
their bubbles but I wrote it in about 15
minutes when you have a good idea it
comes very quickly and it comes kind of
in it in a total complete form so it was
you know I I knew it had to have a heart
I knew it had to feel like an emergency
to some extent in the front you know
it's just I got lucky
other than the original inception in the
original you know writing of thematic
material and the idea and the feeling of
the movie I think the most difficult
thing is rewriting without question you
know a rewriting is is devastating you
know you just feel like you've been
kicked in the gut and you can't imagine
that somebody could be so stupid as to
not understand how right you are
and for you know a longest period of
time that was my attitude I'd say for
the first 10 years I was doing movies I
I felt I knew everything and I didn't
really care what the director had to say
which is really ridiculous and and then
I realized that a lot of times if not
most of the time a director has insights
into the project that I could never have
they've been on it they were involved
with getting the things started they had
they had to tell this story it meant
they meant the world to them and there
are things about it that I need to know
and I realized that part of my
resistance to rewriting had to do with
just physical laziness and I think
everybody must feel that way
you just think can I get it up again to
be that enthusiastic that passionate
that can I believe in any other idea and
the truth is almost without fail every
time I do a rewrite and I feel like I'm
in a clear kind of collaboration and
communication with the director it's
better so I've learned to just take a
deep breath quickly and be thick skins
about thick skinned about it and
understand that rewriting is a big part
of the job to get in this business is a
very difficult thing to begin with and I
always say have a plan B I mean it may
be it it might work out and it might not
it's it if it's going to work out first
of all you're gonna have to stick to it
and be persistent for a long time
possibly be good at some kind of ability
to create electronic music you know be
able to make a good sounding demo lie
yourself with young filmmakers student
filmmakers do it you know pay to pay to
compose music for somebody do whatever
you have to do just to get your music
attached to some visual but I would say
more than anything make sure that your
the the demo you make sounds good
because the technology is so pervasive
now that every mate everybody makes a
good sounding demo they may not have any
substance to it but sometimes a director
can't tell the difference so make sure
that the at least that the music sounds
good that it has good sounding samples
and those can be it acquired fairly
cheaply these days and then just be very
friendly and be willing to rewrite a
whole bunch of times
gosh I didn't really know much about the
business I mean I when I started I you
know I was lucky enough to have an agent
and I think
you need to ally yourself with somebody
you trust who can represent you in all
those areas probably make yourself a
deal with the Performing Rights
Association BMI ASCAP those kinds of
things CSEC and I would protect your
music III would be careful about who you
who you give it to I wouldn't be afraid
to actually give it to somebody and say
you can use my music for free in this
movie because they don't have any money
and they don't they can't pay you but in
a way using your music in a film that
you think is worthy is payment and I
wouldn't get too hung up on the money in
the beginning but you do want to you
don't want to lose the rights to your
music if at all possible and so you
probably need to at least have a
conversation with an attorney if you
start to get an opportunity like that in
the beginning probably I would have I
would have been more relaxed about it I
would have known that it was somehow
always going to get done because I'm
such a hyper responsible student if you
will and when I get an assignment I'm
just I just you know become crazed that
I have to get it done in a certain
amount of time and it's funny when I was
working with Hans Zimmer on our first
Batman Begins collaboration and we were
four or five days away from the first
orchestra date and we hadn't sent
anything out to any orchestrators and I
said Hans you know you're crazy we're
sitting here four days away from
recording we have no orchestrations he
said what day is it I said it's Thursday
say when do we start I said Monday said
we have plenty of time and when he said
that to me I laughed and I realized that
you know composing is supposed to be fun
even when it's difficult and you're
rewriting and you want to pull your hair
out somehow find a way for it to be fun
and appreciate how lucky you are to get
paid to write music
[Music]